what is your assessment of the war
situation at the moment well i think we
can see that this is not the end of the
war
and
a lot of people have their raised
mood they are happy because some of the
ukrainian regions are being liberated
but i don't think it's high time for
saying things like that because a lot of
settlements and regions are being
occupied and a lot of people are being
killed by the russian soldiers the most
complicated is in the east
for them it's important
to control mario paul they're willing to
destroy all of the soldiers in mariopol
than they would proceed uh to the east
in order to try
and surround uh a significant number of
ukrainian soldiers in order to destroy
all of that the russian troops did
withdraw from cave around kiev journey
have
do you think
the capital city is still under threat
it's hard to say
if our forces in donbass won't be able
to hold their positions then the risk of
the repeated offensive against kiev and
the cavaliers is probable a video has
emerged
in which ukrainian soldiers seem to be
executing
russian soldiers in the woods so the
russians are saying also ukrainians are
committing war crimes what do you have
to say about this particular video and
are you investigating this what can you
tell us about this i'm not going to
talking specifically on this or that
occasion our soldiers particularly the
armed forces of ukraine
there's they don't have any reason or
any sense to behave in that manner
towards russian soldiers they
want you to be neutral they want you
going to be a neutral estate you agree
with that but what is your understanding
of that neutrality what are you willing
to accept as a solution for this whole
conflict and more there would be
something some specific agreements that
will make sure that russia will
clearly not
want to violate our sovereignty and
territorial integrity not
launch any other invasion against
ukraine we are ready to
be a non-bloc state we were a non-bloc
country non-aligned country other
countries would be ready to guarantee
our security there's some rules
and in addition to weapons in addition
to their personal protection there is
also sanctions
so it all means that if there will be an
attack against ukraine by any country
these states the security guarantees
will be defending us
why are we talking about russia as a
possible security guarantee
why
because
russia should have a legal
responsibility because if they wouldn't
be there they wouldn't be held liable
this is what we want this is what russia
wants
and frankly speaking
if they wouldn't be dealing with their
domestic victories we would be able to
reach an agreement at this point if you
allow me to end with this personal
question you are
an artist
an actor you're not a military general
now this is a war
and
you have seen so many
difficult things
bodies in the streets of butcher
you are the leader of this country
it's tough for everybody how do you
as a human being emotionally
deal with all of this i feel pain
at certain cases you just get used to to
that and uh to a certain degree it's a
pity that i'm getting used to things
like that
that i look at certain things that i
think not a single person would have
been imagining that they would be
looking at
i think
it's the question of about who you are
and it's not related
with the profession that you need or
what you'll be doing in the future it's
a profession of becoming
or and being the citizen of our country
that's the most important profession
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
thank you for talking to al jazeera
thank you so much
you